welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar tools and
processes for making evidence-based
policy decisions
presented by eugene joann ma senior
research analyst for medical policy and
technology evaluation of independence
Blue Cross
my name is executors and I will be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box on the far left rear screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box our speaker will respond
to your questions via email following
the presentation and if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and the software's
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow your process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Eugene Joann MA I
will now turn the presentation over to
him
Thank You Savior so thanks for the
introduction
yes so a lot to get through today with
this presentation as the title stays
there are multiple tools and there are
multiple processes but one thing I
always like to start off with is my key
and that's also the that key being
evident so we're going to we're going to
revolve around a lot of a lot of as the
title says tools and processes but we're
going to go through some of them in
great detail to understand how policy
positions reimbursement positions in
general decision making is performed for
any sort of you know technology that is
out there medical services clinical
services but today we're gonna focus in
on molecular diagnostic
well for for this particular
presentation I thought that because
given the current environment
what sort of molecular diagnostic realm
would be perfect for the audience in
order to gain the most knowledge but I'm
free yeah so I figured that you know
let's talk about genetic testing okay so
I'm gonna use that as an example but the
tools and processes and and the
intricacies related with apply across
the board for for any sort of molecular
diagnostic decision making regarding
technologies that we'll be talking about
keeping evidence as the key perspective
so for genetic testing and you know
there multiple uses I've listed a number
of examples here
diagnostic testing predictive you know
being prognostic being part of it your
prenatal testing non-invasive prenatal
has been a hot topic for for some years
screening and then you know one of the
favorites for many in the industry as
well like emia pharmacogenetic testing
for therapeutic purposes for monitoring
purposes so again just to highlight that
there's multiple usages and we will be
talking about today of how to go about
evaluating the evidence or for these
type of test dates
there's uniformity of course there's
gonna be some specificities that that we
would have to consider as you go along
but I want I want to provide general
frameworks which can be used for all
these different varieties of oh just
wanted to since I gave you background
regarding multiple are multiple
different fields that you know our
frameworks that we talked about can
apply to let's try to dwindle it down
and and you know talk about how the
questioning may start so you can we we
can divide up labrum into diagnostic
prognostic again the general questions
would remain the same they will be
talking about and going over
how useful is the test up to par is it
doing what it's supposed to do but if
you wanted to make make your question
narrower you can you can you can decide
if it's a diagnostic as the prognostic
or therapeutic and then on the on the
right side you will see all to start you
will see that you didn't even get
further into more details are you what
is your population patient population
are you dealing with symptomatic
individuals are you dealing with
asymptomatic individuals are you doing
testing where you know you need to know
the history of family members as well
and then going down even further in the
symptomatic population are you talking
about German language most manic
variation within the variation are you
are you dealing with benign versus
likely path versus pathogenic variation
or or are you working within within
variation of but there's a number of
questions that start and it's really
important to have those drilled down
before you get into your evaluation
pieces but that's what's going to decide
further questioning and also at the sort
of evidence and that you'll be looking
for and selecting and then making an
eventual decision based on how good that
evidence is sufficient is it of high
quality or not we will talk about those
points a little later on and then also
you know under the eye a symptomatic
population I have screening and DTC
stands for direct but what kind of
testing it so I just wanted to provide
some examples in that in that sort of
realm as well and you know one of the
one of the other things that we have to
keep back of it is regulatory
environment when it comes to genetic
testing
you know FDA is feeling is way out there
getting more involved over the past few
years we have you know they in the kid's
world because it's it's designated as a
device as the approval is required and
then I have examples of companion
diagnostics so for companion
some of you may have heard of examples
of regarding some test that where FDA
and CMS which is you know they have
partnered to do parallel reviews in
order to understand and come up with
positioning regarding companion
diagnostic or your pharmacogenetic tests
that are out there and so do you have
examples where you know there's
regulatory bodies and this is specific
to the US but it's across the board in
the UK and other European countries and
eighteen countries as well and just just
wanted to highlight in this slide that
if if a particular testing or our
diagnostic therapeutic piece or a
prognostic lab requires radical removal
it's really important to study that and
understand it and see what the approval
is for and everything USA you obviously
have for laboratory development develop
test CLIA approvals we think if you guys
are more questions you're more than
welcome to share them with me and I'll
try my best to explain this particular
field murky at this time a hard applies
to genetic testing first for instance
specifically but I can answer those
question all right so let's let's get
into let's get into the decision making
framework what I won't be discussing
today is USPSTF ECAP and dtt just wanted
to list them there to state that there
are more examples of what other than
what I'm gonna be talking about so maybe
in a future presentation I'll go with
that however I decided to today talk
about I I'll get into what that means
the ACCE model and then the p-cards
model so let's talk about that so some
folks are familiar with BC BSA which has
to cross blue shield association they
take like a is the technology assessment
is the analytical framework of how to
critically analyze and ask the correct
questions regarding any sort of a
clinical medical service and when I say
technology that's what I mean medical
clinical service including laboratory
testing it's a framework which is
extremely useful used by multiple
organizations over the years and you
know something that can be extremely
useful even when you're developing the
sort of evidence for for the testing
that that your task but you know
developing and then bringing to the
market and then eventually bring to the
clinical world and if you're in the
business of evaluating evidence to come
up with a positive position this is a
great framework so there's multiple
question that you asked we talked about
number one the technology must have fine
approval from the appropriate government
factory bodies we I talked about that in
in a couple of slides ago so so just pay
attention to that if it's supposed to
have a private or approver does it have
it or not the second one is the second
point is there's scientific evidence
must permit conclusions concerning the
effect of that on health outcomes so
that's where we get into what sort of
study designs I require what sort of
sample sizes
what kind of statistical analyses are
required in order for you to reach a
conclusion that the test is clinically
valid or useful it's performing the
services it's it's itching that it is
actually doing so the peer reviewed
evidence the publications must permit
those conclusions you are you need to
have those conclusions there shouldn't
be any gray area if there's any
limitations or biases involved in the
overall aggregate evidence that you're
dealing with for the particular lab
service that that you're evaluating and
then the basic evidence is not letting
you make definitive conclusions and
you're in the sort of experimental
investigational further studies are
needed to answer the outstanding
question you know arena for for the
particular questioning that you're doing
the third point is technology must
improve the net so we can get more in
detail about that but just for now the
understanding of this is that the
benefits that you're getting the
benefits that you're getting from the
service that you're evaluating it should
those benefits should outweigh the risks
the fourth point the technology must be
as beneficial as an established that
alternate can be doing nothing as the
traditional way of dealing with the
indication or the indication we're
talking about so or it could be that
there are there are other methods other
that has other monitoring services that
are available whatever you are
evaluating be it a battery of tests or
singular tests per panel as the results
of those and the clinical outcomes that
you that are the primary clinical
outcomes that you're achieving through
those that testing should be clinically
equivalent or superior to to the
establishment or the traditional way or
the the what is what is part of routine
clinical care right down the clinic and
that sort of leads us to the the fifth
point which is the improvement must be
attainable outside and what that means
is that in the simplest term that
whatever you bring into the marketplace
or you're introducing it has to become
part of routine clinical care so the
average patient which fits the criteria
for whatever testing is being performed
the physician group or the healthcare
provider is employing that testing
across the board for every patient that
fits that particular criteria so
basically routine clinical care is
equivalent to that so the point I would
like to read that I think is extremely
important so at the end of the day the
evidence reviews assess whether a
medical test is clinically useful a
useful test
information to make a clinical
management decision that improves the
net health outcomes a lot of buzzwords
they're clinically useful the testing
has clinically useful it the results
that you get from it or should have
direct patient management impacts and
you need to be improving the net health
outcomes that that are desired so at the
end of the day the the next three lines
I think I've gone over it but if you if
you eat the quotations and make that the
goal doing your evidence develops then
of what sort of studies of a sort of
evidence you need to be publishing for
for your labs to let you get reimbursed
or to have medical ancestry positions
for them those are that those are keys
to keep in mind let's get into CDC
stands for center of Disease Control at
a CCE model the slide you guys have I
will give you a couple of seconds to
sort of you know have it at your if you
like there but I'll try to provide
references across the board they're
extremely useful and if you have any
questions or need for the references or
these references more than welcome to
reach out to me through lab roads so the
ACC e stands for instance for analytic
validity I introduce technical validity
at that point to the first C stands for
clinical validity the second the third
the second C stands for clinical utility
a lot to say there and then the e stands
for any epic ethical concerns this is
another model and I think majority of
the audience is going to be familiar
with this but I'll go into a bit more
detail about it because this is the keys
framework that comes during discussions
in order to make any sort of evidence
policy decisions or to evaluate if if
any is ready for the point or there's a
lot of questioning that goes into it
again I would encourage you to turn to
the references that I have listed but
let's get into a brief synopsis of what
at least the ECC is
so like I said instance for analytic
validity the technical validity to
summarize what that is is is your test
accurate or precise technical
sensitivity and specificity numbers is
it is it picking up what is supposed to
do so and in the genetic testing world
is it picking up the variant that it's
is claiming to pick up or multiple
variants depending on the testing but
you so take-home message is is the test
accurate or precise and I get into more
detail in the the slide but again I like
to bring out the buzzwords when there's
a lot on the site is it accurate and
reliable I mean you keep repeating it
best thing is it going to pick up the
variance or whatever you know mutation
or mutations that it's staining that it
will within but then gene markers or any
sort of markers that are that are out
there the second point is clinical
validity see CV okay and I'm sure that
multiple of the audience have have heard
this before but what I like to explain
this is the genotype to phenotype
correlation a fortunate test that are
out there is there biological relevance
and for this it would be before the
testing is being developed or medicine
in the sort of conceptual phase these
are the these are the questions that
would be asked does it make biological
sense if you're dealing with one mark or
multiple markers you know clinical
validity for all of those needs to be
needs to be established here's where the
clinical sensitivity so in the previous
slide I was on the sensitivity and
specificity in this particular and
therefore this particular requirement
you'll be looking at things such as
clinical sensitivity and specificity
your NPV PPV numbers negative predictive
value positive predictive values and the
evidence and the level of evidence that
been behind generating those numbers
these are all part of the evidence
reviews in order to come up to see if
the testing
once you're going to become part of
routine clinical care is it medically
necessary or not and this is a very
prime and major major point of
evaluation as you go to the evidence for
any sort of aesthetic knowledge that you
are evaluating then our friend the
biggest requirement there is clinical
utility now like I said before before I
get into details about this like I said
before there are many different types of
testing that are out there and then even
when you try to you know reduce them to
the diagnostic prognostic therapeutic
world you know it's world still there's
gonna be variation but the common theme
is these days
the first offical industry you may ask a
several very specific targeted questions
depending on what you're evaluating but
at the end of the day clinical utility
is that the evidence has to show that
the results that you're getting from
your testing are having direct patient
impact on direct patient management so
in the diagnostic world is it diagnosing
correctly and then it's leading to the
correct selection of whatever is it
monitoring next are we going to be doing
a referral whatever whatever there is is
having a direct impact on its leading
you where's that in the entire Punic
world unless you know that's that's an
example that that is easier to
understand the testing that you're
performing are they are they having are
they helping you select the correct
therapeutic option or options they're
there or are they are they telling you
what not to use as a verb so clinical
utility results and and evidence behind
it to support the quality and quantity
of that evidence becomes extremely
important and this is where you know a
lot of the testing that is in the
marketplace this is this is a prime
requirement before reaching a medical
necessity level and then obviously you
have our you know ethical legal and
social implications and again I would in
encourage you to you know look at the
references and study more about it this
for the sake of time I will spend that
with upon it the next figure I am sure
the 99.9% of the audience has seen it
either during their academic you know
experiences or as they move to industry
or their professional world
this is hierarchy of evidence you will
see many different variation of this
pyramid or as explained but this lays
the groundwork of sort of quality that
goes behind it so I talked about a lot
of the measurements and a lot of the
requirements behind the evidence but
this shows you that as you go up up this
pyramid of how the quality increases and
obviously it's not stated here but in
order to move up this pyramid it becomes
harder and harder from a logistical
perspective to but this is sort of to
give give the idea that you know why is
having a case case report or multiple
case report a case series is is likely
not going to be enough to establish
clinical utility why you need to move
into control studies and if possible
into randomized control studies because
you're reducing the bias ease and moving
up and you're able to pinpoint exactly
that the outcomes that are that are
being reported are actually you can you
can trace them back to the sort of
information or the testing that we talk
so again you see different variations of
this but this is for further evidence
progresses when it comes to quality
piece of it then I'll talk about the
quantity and you can't let go of the
importance of quantity I mean you're
taking a look at it but it varies again
percentage paths so let's let's get into
the analytic or technical validity what
kind of evidence are we talk about this
line discusses you know the high
confidence in order to establish a
political community become if you have
multiple size
participating there multiple locations
or not
or groups that have performed the
testing in order to validate it there's
a there's a large number of samples ever
involved these peer review publications
of that number so what you see is a lot
of time this data is for pie okay but if
you publish it and it's available it has
gone through the peer review process
that gives you that gives you additional
additional credibility to establish that
accuracy and precision that you need to
order or to establish the analytic or
technical validity and then you know if
you have regulatory body involvement and
they give it a check for you that's also
a big positive so in the next generation
sequencing world the platforms that are
involved you see that they're at this
point if a test is employing a
next-generation sequencing methodology
for those platforms unless they're
grading questions it's in 2019 is taken
that you know the platforms have
technical analytic validity established
and you would move on to the next step
which would be clinical validity so this
I would encourage the audience to
definitely the paper is a couple of
years old or less than two years old but
it's still relevant that reference I
really like it
I try to use it a lot during the
presentations form they're from this
particular reference I described how the
level of clinical validity when it comes
to evidence is established the good news
here is you don't need control or
randomized studies in order to establish
clinical validity for whatever testing
you bring it to the marketplace if you
see on the slide yeah independently
cohort case controller family linkage
studies maybe in Mouse to establish the
genotype to phenotype correlation that
you're trying to do but where this is
this is I would like to take a pause
here and and and and spend some more
time on it so when to talk about panel
testing on your test occur
simultaneously for multiple markers at
the same time in your testing what
happens is that unless say you
looking at markers of different kinds
there may be clinical validity that you
know type if you have the correlation if
your markers are genes for instance for
a couple or one or two to three but what
about the rest of the fifteen or sixteen
or seventeen markers in my example of
the eighteen marker panel you need to
have clinical validity for as many or
preferably all of the markers that make
up make up your test a so so that point
is extremely important but this life
discusses with you of so this is in the
development of testing this is where
this is where you would just use period
literature that has been published in
order to come up with the markers and
that can serve as when you're getting
questions regarding clinical validity by
by any organization those are the
submissions that you would like to like
to make but again I guess you can use
observational studies a cohort so every
prospective analysis is a perfectly fine
depending on the situation but they
still have to be the quantity may have
to be large depending on the testing to
bring to the market so it may not be as
one course that it does enough it may be
you know two to five studies with enough
large sample size in order to have the
confidence in the in establish of
clinical validity again there's gonna be
variations if you're talking about a
rare a rare disease obviously the
prevalence numbers are not there so the
sample size ask is not going to be as
large but if you're dealing with a
chronic condition that can have a large
patient population obviously the sample
sizes required are going to be larger so
just keep those points in mind and then
our friend clinical utility and here's a
lot of again I don't have time to today
to talk about you know direct versus
indirect evidence that can establish
thank you so I'm gonna focus on direct
evidence and you see that you're
obviously the best way currently to
establish console utility would be
you know do buzz design and kind of
replicated RCTs randomized us now this
is where a lot of impasse occurs between
and organization then the full tour
party get reimbursed or trying to
establish clinical utility or medical
necessity for their testing that all our
cities are not you know feasible or the
best way to go about it why canticle
that's the discussion for another
presentation and you know I hope I get
to discuss that in in the next year
years to come but but for now this is a
good time primer to have to see how in
order to establish clinical utility for
your testing knowledge that you're
bringing the marketplace who are
utilizing or developing or having
discussions about this is the kind of
data and again what is clinical utility
going to establish is going to showcase
that the results that you're painting
from you technology results our tests
are having a direct impact on whatever
patient management that is desired at
the end of the game over the criteria
look like again the first bullet is you
know explains itself the second third
and fourth bullet of what we just talked
about and the test is as the technical
numbers the technical sensitivity and
specificity is accurate and precise it
has been established it's like the third
bullet point on the slide is what I've
been talking about the clinical validity
its genotype to phenotype correlation
based on the evidence that the correct
quality and quantity of evidence
showcase is that the clinical validity
is there for the testing all the markers
if you have multiple markers in your
testing it has been established for
those and again I say that with the
disclaimer about you have discussions it
may be that a sufficient number of
markers have it because we're at that
point now where obviously if you have a
300 plus marker panels has highly
unlikely and I would like to say almost
I'm a hundred percent I can say with
confidence that the clinical validity
for all
300 of those Marcus has that we
establish but that's a discussion and
again you can ask in your questions
about that we can I can explain further
more of how that discussion may go and
what to do in those situations and then
the last bullet extremely extremely
important this is where a lot of a lot
of the conflicts happen unfortunately
because the evidence is missing for the
clinical utility piece and I'll repeat
it the peer reviewed not anecdotal that
posters not abstracts peer reviewed data
publish publish data establish it
establishes the objective effects of the
essays also on direct management and
care of the individual for all
applicable indications and clinical
situations to verify clinical utility of
the test so a lot of buzzwords there if
you're dealing multiple indications the
test has to perform well across the
board does have to have a direct
correlation and direct impact on on
patient management whatever the poor
clinical protocols are in place so again
it's going to actually be extremely
important but for the sake of time I'll
move on but this slide is extremely
important this is odd if you have a
medic investigator would get asked for
it I would skip over this side and come
back to it it's the PCAST model which I
will explain in later size what it means
but this is a good example of how to go
about it I included it in here because I
wanted to share the reference with you
with you folks so again I encourage I'm
I'm really big on references and going
back and for for my for my audience to
go back and study them in greater detail
because obviously these are huge topics
and a 45 minute or even an hour
presentation is probably not good enough
to get the gist effect so please please
go to this particular reference I would
highly encourage it and any other ones
that I have studied there is a reason I
cite them because I want you guys to go
and read further on it alright so let's
get into the peak hotspot of
so what have you talked about so far we
have talked about okay we have talked
about the easy model but more and more
you also see CIC to see OTS and again
eyes again crazy and AHRQ I'm using that
them as a base this particular model
which which can be used for evaluations
and again it's not limited to just labs
or the diagnostic or therapeutic or
prognostic was for any sort of you can
use this for devices you can use this
for any sort of other medical or
clinical you know care or service that
is providing order to see if the
evidence threshold for them is at a
level where they can be used for routine
clinical here they're answering the
questions in order to establish their
medical necessity so let's let's go
through this P stands for patient
patient population you have to define
your patient population so in pikas P
ICO TS the P is for patient population
you have to define it sometimes you may
have to get into sub population this is
where you define the if you are
concerned about certain age you're
concerned about maybe you know stage
three versus stage four cancer what type
of care are you just concerned about the
primary populations are or are you again
like I said there's subpopulations that
are involved this is where this is this
is all this all goes back to questioning
this is where you establish your
questions and defining your patient
operation important because that's going
to drive all of the further questioning
that you have so paying attention to
this is extremely important goes without
saying i stands for interment it's
whatever I like I said these frameworks
apply to not just testing but for any
sort of technologies that you're
evaluating intervention is whatever you
introduce it what are you gathering
evidence for that
going to bring bring to the picture of
the clinical scenario and it's going to
make a difference and this is this is
where you know the claims that are being
made about the extremely important just
be careful if you're saying that the
interesting is going to do X Y Z a
priori your your your publication
results in the peer-reviewed literature
have to show that because that's that
this was what is being claimed and the
rest of it is explained on the slide so
I won't get into that see is the
comparator right so how this is where
the comparative studies become important
but I would like to take a pause here
and and and sort of explain this further
a lot of times what we see is that the
comparative studies are being performed
there they are they're being talked
about Oh X does better than Y right and
Y is the traditional way or the
established way of doing things
correctly what I try to make sure I tell
my audience all the time during my
presentations is that make sure that X
is actually medically necessary begin
with before you can compare X to Y with
Y being the established way of doing
things or traditional way of doing
things you have to first establish that
X is achieving the clinical outcomes
that it's stating that it would be
enough evidence for it but before you
get into its comparative studies first
make sure that the technology lab
testing whatever your your I is
intervention is is performing at a
medically necessary level before you
save you before you state that at that
particular intervention is clinically
superior to anything else that is
currently available and that includes
again not doing anything just this
monitoring or just monitoring as we just
keep that in mind that I try to make
sure I deliver that point to it my talk
so the oh let's talk about the onp cards
EW Oh tears again because our stands for
outcomes
I've becomes extremely poor and goes
without saying and you know this is
where you need to I give you to
establish your primary outcomes versus
secondary outcomes and have had the
correct epidemiological principles a
statistical analyses in order to
establish the primary outcomes in order
to take a look at your data when you're
doing your publications because that's
what what is going to be looked at
during the evidence evaluations for
these was decided a priori what sort of
ad hoc analyses were performed and what
and how what importance do they bring
bring to the table and can and that hoc
analysis for example be taken you know
to establish significance or not another
important point is to distinguish
between a clinical significance is
physical significant it may turn out
that the clinical significance is also
extreme importance and if that is not
established for the situation the
statistical significance achievement of
statistical significance may not be may
not be enough in order to establish
medical necessity and then also you know
this is where your appropriate sample
size or or again like I say analyses
that have been decided that are going to
perform the data becomes extremely
important birthday frankly chosen and
then also you know the quantity and
quality is it that there is sufficient
aggregate data to to verify you know the
the primary outcome results that that
are that are being discussed or they're
being pitched as being enough in order
to move forward with the medical for
instance or is the quality good enough
if we were supplies if what I talked
about in some previous slides if you're
supposed to have you know while design
control studies and even have an
introduction of randomization in your
studies and those are the only ways in
order for you to establish you know that
versus clinical utility or establish
medical necessity
our to come up with which would criteria
or where your technology or testing
would be appropriate is if the design is
not good enough
study or studies going back to the
pyramid for example that I just asked
then further testing is required because
there's limitations in evidence
the biases that are present in the
whatever the publish evidence that is
available at that time when the
valuations been performed I cannot be
ignored because there's also all these
all these things come into play when
you're looking at not just a lot but the
but I wanted to make sure that I gave
you enough again buzzwords here for you
to ask further questions if needed or to
go out and and and and and look at the
references or for further you know
information that you that you need in
order to make sure that the right
quantity and quality of evidence is
being produced and it's being evaluated
in the correct way it stands for timing
it's this is where the longitudinal
study is the short term outcomes good
enough or or or do you need long term
outcomes it's six months good enough is
my data good enough or do you really
want me to monitor for for for for a
couple of years for instance but again
this is all going to be defined by the
exact questions or the intervention and
sort of what we talked about if the
first three or four slides what kind of
testing intervention or Technology where
we are talking about but making sure
that the T timing part of it is
important as well setting this is this
is this is also part of the P class
model and overall value framework that
is being used so I think this slide
explains itself it becomes extremely
important it becomes relevant again
depending on that you have but again
just wanted to include this in here for
you to be aware of it and I think a
large percentage of you this may may not
be applicable but you never know
situation you can turn into but just is
having having this knowledge that the
setting achievement of your outcome in
the focus setting if the setting is
relevant becomes extremely important to
when Ivan is being looked at
again situation dependent here right
this is this is towards the end of the
presentation okay I want to highlight
what is it every try to achieve here
whatever trials whatever the clinical
evidence is out there it should have
high strength of evidence that this goes
back to having the correct type of
studies the quantity and quality of
clinical investigations that are peer
reviewed and published in not anecdotal
not abstract not posters and they mean
this is the highlight of the bullet
points or the highlight of what they
should be showcasing they have a low
risk of bias I talked about bias in my
in my in my in my presentation today
that as you go up that pyramid biases
are reduced this advocate power to
address subgroups we talked about
population which I talked about how sub
population subgroups you need to define
them correctly what is power mean enough
sample size big enough sample size for
your study or studies aggregate is big
enough or your or your primary seminal
work has a large enough sample size that
is required in order for you to other
clinical validity or clinical utility
and then let's let's look at the second
bullet examine clinical strategy
complexities that are more likely to be
replicated in practice remember we
talked about routine clinical care your
data your evidence has to show and we
talked about you know any average a
patient walking in that meets the
clinical context for which you are
pitching your technology or test before
the outcomes that it comes need to be
achieved
similarly cross the border for for those
those advocating that a part of your
population and so that's where that's
where it sort of the second bullet gets
you to that you should be you your your
results should be similar you know there
shouldn't be any it should be
reliability in them and you in order for
you to become part of the first bullet
again goes back to our you know patients
defining your population accurate
and because eventually when you do get a
data you have to be able to apply to
publish if there's too much variation
but your populations not being accounted
for that can be that can be a limitation
that Center studies or investigations
have to overcome if you are deciding to
do you know further evidence development
and then you know I wanted to just bring
up a couple of things that you don't
have time for today
there are two consumer testing and then
also pricing on going hard that is a
team again a future presentation for me
I would like to address these but if you
have so many pressing questions that you
want to bring in for these more than
welcome care through lab routes and that
concludes my presentation
for today I hope it was useful and again
questions or any verifications that are
needed I encourage you to reach out to
me through lab roads thank you for your
time
Thank You Eugene for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible and as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye